welcome to this video playing let's go
before against Carosi row from Spain and
modern defense belts defense something
like that yeah
see five
hmm yeah I screwed up man with water him
I usually played this a three-line
against that and this um prevents e5
okay this is no problem it's a it's a
theoretical position but not what I
wanted to want to play
I wonder Bishop III is this Queen before
or something
maybe maybe cover that I don't know
don't know the exact lines iam yeah the
some is some quite similar to to a
Sicilian seeing that dragon kind of
formation with the white having gas on
short
hmm I don't like the noise here should
try to reroute that a motif that I know
is 97 c3 95 this is quite embarrassing
it happened to happen in Grandmaster
games not exactly in this position I
mean but in general it's a it's a known
way to screw up okay so why not have
five here I'm a bit surprised that he
that he willingly closed up his bishop
without any need really
okay
the question is should I take I could
play well queen g3 you can take it you
fall it's a bit bit our dream okay so
that's let's take him this is the kind
of position that you can very hardly
lose as white but not easy to make any
headway probably check it's no big point
and keeping this on the space
yeah this position the bishop on d3 is
quite strong it protects the c2 weakness
and supports play on the Kings side and
my ideas rookie form some are using the
rook on the fourth rank maybe h4 h5
trying on the Kings side and the me
target he has no return to play because
some this is Bishop alone secures the
Queen side
I'm not saying that said that it's a
terrible food black it's just like I'm
I'm at risk very little him because my
position is so on nicely coordinated for
care for
happy 7 is hanging as well I cannot
really move the bishop maybe use the H
bone as well H 5 H 6
it's not tuned not so easy
yeah maybe even g4g 4g5 but it's not
yeah
it's not a winning and he's threatening
Queen III but it let's let's check this
briefly H I can't play at 5:00 why not
Queen takes rook at 6:23 I can take h6
and win the piece okay this service I
didn't didn't calculate even which is
maybe a mistake yeah I still got Queen
III so I need to money to prevent them
the Queen's Red Queen g3 to c7 also also
a good good motif okay this wasn't the
right way to go
probably will get five after all
I'm down to one something
yeah yeah this is not the way to go
hmm yeah I guess it was very good at one
point but I I screwed it up
yeah this is probably a drawn draw
Alfred
generally our own it's not much point in
continuing I mean I have absolutely
nothing
this is all protecting each other
h6 g5 and so on now
but where did I screw it up it looked at
looked excellent around here okay I
played h5 hippie took and what's known
yeah the computers is just so so precise
yeah that looks the good movie is king
edge one yeah yeah once you see it you
you you recognize the merit of this now
he can't play this because simply it
hangs on f6 it's no check it's getting
another check and this means I'm
threatening look at five now and this is
really really terrible I have something
like this there's no check on h1
it basically means that I'm attacking
now with all my pieces and he doesn't
have a counterplay check in the game he
managed to to get to get the Queen self
this was still quite nice
probably but chanted this it's it's just
wrong and the computer still thinks
before if I've some some keep it more
fun this is clearly better for white but
ok I didn't have the nerve for that
yeah but King h1 this is this is really
a move to to to remember that very often
this is some actually a well known booty
from Kasparov's games that right in the
middle of an attack he plays a
cautionary kings and this would have
been really strong him yeah enough to
kind of move probably that you find in a
blitz game unless you're but lucky I'll
have the super sharp Dame and here black
is really busted he's got no way to
defend this yeah interesting
thanks for watching